and to those who think we should reject
this deal in favor of No Deal because we
cannot get every assurance we want
I asked what would a No Deal brexit do
to strengthen the hand of those
campaigning for Scottish independence or
Indies those demanding a border poll in
Northern Ireland surely this is the real
threat to our union mr. speaker mr.
speaker with just 74 days until the 29th
of March the consequences of voting
against this deal tomorrow are becoming
ever clearer with no deal we would have
no implementation period no security
partnership no guarantees for UK
citizens overseas and no certainty for
businesses and workers like those I met
in Stoke this morning and we will see
changes to everyday life in Northern
Ireland that would put the future of our
union at risk and if rather than leaving
with no deal this house blocked brexit
that would be of subversion of our
democracy saying to the people
saying to the people we were elected to
serve that we were unwilling to do what
they had instructed